[MUSIC PLAYING]
With Servant, the reason Sean and Julian don't
have the conversation with Dorothy
about what really happened, they're
scared they're going to lose her.
I saw what you made in the basement
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's a contingency.
Sean mustn't know about that.
They'll do anything to not have this conversation and nine,
you see that the stakes are extremely high for this family.
We don't have to do this.
Jericho needs his family today.
It's his first Christmas.
This episode is a very pivotal moment.
It's supposed to be the day that Jericho is
going to return, Christmas Eve.
Aah, the banquet is complete.
They're having this very kind of weird dinner
while they're waiting for this baby to come home.
And meanwhile, Julian is spiraling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He feels like he's less.
And he keeps on going farther away from himself.
And it culminates in a very scary moment.
(SCREAMING)
Call 911!
Everything in this show is an interpretation.
Leanne's always exhibited potential powers.
And what happens in nine, was it luck?
Was it random?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Can she bring people back from the dead?
I like that it's right on the edge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]